♪♪♪
>>> CHAD!
CHAD!
>> OH, WHAT UP MISS HDLER?
>> HEY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
CHAD -- NO, CHAD, WE CAN'T DO
THIS ANY MORE.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> WAIT, I COULDN'T SLEEP LAST
NIGHT.
>> I HATE THAT.
>> WHAT AM I DOING?
AM I SOME BORED HOUSEWIFE WHO'S
HAVING AN AFFAIR WITH HER
23-YEAR-OLD POOL BOY?
I MEAN, WHAT IS THIS?
>> YOUR KITCHEN.
>> NO, I MEAN US.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND, BUT WE
HAVE TO END THIS.
>> OKAY.
>> I HAD NO IDEA IT WOULD BE
THIS HARD, IT'S JUST WHEN AT
FIRST --
>> CHAD!
>> WHAT UP?
>> YOU DESERVE AN EXPLANATION.
>> OH, OKAY, COOL.
>> LOOK, YOU'VE DONE NOTHING
WRONG, OKAY?
I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BETTER, BUT
I DON'T KNOW, IT WAS JUST -- IT
WAS FUN.
IT WAS NEW.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT MY GOD, I'M A MARRIED
WOMAN WITH THREE KIDS.
MY HUSBAND'S ON THE CITY
COUNCIL.
I'M THE PTA PRESIDENT AT
MELANIE'S SCHOOL.
>> WHO'S MELANIE?
>> MY DAUGHTER.
>> OKAY.
>> IF THIS GOT OUT, IT WOULD
RUIN MY LIFE, OUR FAMILY'S
LIVES.
>> MY BAD.
>> ALL I WANT TO DO IS HAVE YOU
CLEAR THE BAGS OFF THIS TABLE
AND TAKE ME RIGHT NOW.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT YOU C'T.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> BECAUSE I LEARNED THAT
SOMETIMES GETTING WHAT YOU WANT
MEANS LOSING WHAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE.
♪♪♪
>> LOOK, I WROTE THIS FOR YOU
LAST NIGHT.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> OH, MY GOD, I'M BLUSHING, I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW I'M NOT A
VERY GOOD WRITER, OKAY?
AND IT'S NOT SOPHISTICATED, BUT
IT'S HOW I FEEL.
I JUST -- I MEAN EVERY WORD OF
WHAT I WROTE.
>> WHOA!
I FOUND A DEAD SQUIRREL IN YOUR
POOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BYE CHAD.
>> HELLO?
>> WHAT UP?
>> WHERE'S PHILLIP?
>> MY UNCLE HIRED ME, I'M GOING
TO BE DOING YOUR HOUSE NOW.
I'M TOBY ABOUT.
>> OH, [ BLEEP ].